[Music]
hey everybody i'm michael mccaffrey the
resident film critic here at rt and we
need to talk about the new sopranos
movie the many saints of newark i'll be
honest with you
now the sopranos is the godfather of the
prestige tv era it is one of the
greatest tv shows of all time tony
soprano is one of the greatest tv
characters of all time and the late
james gandolfini gave one of the
greatest performances in television
history as tony soprano so i love the
sopranos anything sopranos related i am
definitely interested in now the many
saints of newark it bills itself as a
prequel to the soprano
when i was a kid
guys like me were brought up to follow
coach
hey jerkle
so when i went to see the movie that's
what i was expecting but that's not
exactly what it is the problem is is
that this two-hour movie if you just cut
it in half and had it be one hour
episodes of the sopranos those two
episodes would be the worst episodes in
the series by a mile the problem is is
that it's very structurally flawed and
that the movie is trying to go in a
million different directions but never
actually gets anywhere so for instance
the film opens making you think that
it's the origin story for christopher
moltesanti now christopher moltesanti
just to remind you in the tv series he
is tony soprano's younger cousin who you
haven't seen the show spoiler alert tony
murders
but then the filmmakers quickly shift
that perspective and their perspective
goes to a young tony soprano what'd you
say what who as a young child and as a
teenager they sort of make you think
that oh the story will be told from his
point of view and it maybe it'll be the
origin story of tony soprano it would be
great but that's not what it is either
because it shifts again and it ends up
following this character dickie
moltesanti i wanna do a good deed now
the dicky moltasanti character he is
christopher montesanti's dad and tony
soprano's uncle and mentor and the movie
follows him as he goes through the life
and times of sort of a mid-level mob
boss but that's just not very
interesting that character is very
cliched and derivative he's sort of a
watered down sonny corleone or tommy
from the from goodfellas we've seen this
character a million times before in a
million better mob movies than this one
but the most inexplicable decision the
movie makes is that it ends up spending
an inordinate amount of time focusing on
the topic of race in newark new jersey
in the late 1960s it's true
this is just a very strange choice
because yes
race in newark new jersey in the late
1960s is a fascinating topic and one
definitely deserving of its own film but
that film it shouldn't be a sopranos
film right the the strange thing is is
that this topic it doesn't drive forward
the sopranos narrative and it doesn't
give any insight into the sopranos
characters that we've all come to to
know and love or loathe now those
characters are in the movie you know so
paulie walnuts and sill and uncle junior
and big [ __ ] they're all there at a
younger age but they get short shrift
because the filmmakers decide to focus
on this issue of race it's really really
unnecessary and it made me think that
the filmmakers were just using sopranos
ip as sort of a gateway drug or delivery
system for them to signal their virtue
over social justice issues or to
politically pander to a specific
audience that they want to treat it's
just really really unnecessary
distracting and frustrating and the end
result is that this ends up being a
rather misguided meandering
middling misfire of a mob movie and it
really could have been so much more and
it should have been so much more
ultimately i watch this movie so you
don't have to and unfortunately you
really don't have to alright we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you